Linda in Tennessee says unfortunately I
allowed myself to fall into the credit
card game I have two cards with the same
balance card one charges 27.9%
interest card two charges nine point
nine which one do I attack and pay off
first or if they're the same balances
you'd pay off the high interest rate
first but I think there's a bigger
problem Linda the Bible says out of the
abundance of the heart the mouth speaks
what's going on inside of you causes you
to choose the words that you use you
need to stop talking like you're talking
I allowed myself to fall into the credit
card game no you didn't you walked
straight up signed up for the card there
was no falling you're not a victim
you walked straight up and signed up for
stupid and you did it on purpose
own it I've done a lot dumber than
you've done kiddo but I walked straight
up and signed up for stupid and as long
as I blamed the government or I blamed
the mean old bank or I blamed the IRS or
I blame the economy I was not getting
any better and I did i sat around and
whined like it wasn't like I was a form
of Prayer but you got to own it you
didn't fall into credit card that you
ever hear anybody say I was forced to
buy a car
well bullcrap you were not no one has
ever forced you to do anything they
didn't have a gun at the car dealerships
by car I'm gonna shoot you
there was no collusion there was no
extortion you weren't forced to buy a
car you wanted a freaking car and you
rationalize the crud out of it stop
lying to yourself it's one of the steps
you have to take to get your life
straightened out
so you didn't allow yourself to fall you
walk straight up and signed up for
stupid say it like it is and it'll help
you in the healing process I know
because I had to go through the same
thing kiddo